junge letzte karte ich weiß nicht wenn
ich das jetzt richtig sei es geworden
ich sage service erst geht's und
herzlich willkommen zu einem neuen video
heute mit den zwei professionellen
spieletester nia 10 und maximilian emir
und heute leute machen wir das was ich
schon seit ewigkeiten machen wollte so
lange saß ich schon daran dachte mir ich
will unbedingt youtuber quartett spielen
die nächste frei gemacht dass selbst ist
viel aufwand und dann habe ich
herausgefunden dass das schon geld ich
hab's ja bestellt hier ist es spielt
heute und zwar sollte so sieht das aus
keine werbung übrigens ich habe mir das
selbst bestellt selbst bezahlt kopf ich
das nicht ist es viel zu teuer ist fast
zehn euro pro person
die erste karte die uns hier an lächelt
ist groß und wir sehen es gibt die
kategorien abonnenten gesamte views
anzahl videos kanal staat arm und
aufrufe auch beliebt ist das video das
sind die kategorien im youtube quartett
wir haben wie gesagt 32 karten haben
auch sara sagt smid muss sagen dass ich
seit ewigkeiten kein konzert mehr
gespielt und ich glaube registrieren so
werden in welche kategorie gezählt wird
und wenn ja dann die höchsten nicht nur
den besten wert hat dann bekommt ihr
alle anderen karten die daten wenn einer
alle karten habt dann hat derjenige muss
ein bisschen schlauer spiel weil es gibt
youtuber die haben viele aufrufe wie
beliebt ist das video und dann gibt's
youtuber die sind einfach nur scheiße
als 1 200 leute wissen zu dritt das
heißt jeder ziehen und zwar ein bisschen
raus gezogen werden du schmeißt man 2
raus diese sind ja nein mag sein und
welche youtube flickr aus maxdorf
vorgesehen
[Musik]
kritisch war anfängt zuerst schere stein
papier okay an als normal aus dem papier
ich sage anzahl videos 6475 das virtual
and play
ok ich bekomme ein baby und upgrades und
nicht dafür kann man sagen okay krass
kanalstadt an
das ist heftig zweiter juli 2009
alter schwede jahres 5 23 02 09 2007
peas meet me in oftersheim der
abonnenten 199 millionen 3,4
du wirst mir ja 4,74 gewonnen
okay auch nicht schlecht ich sage
kanalstadt am 14 oktober 2007 von minus
2 14
hier steht spezialeffekt körbchengröße
doch wer wird leider keine chance den er
auch keine chance gegen lukas ok aufrufe
auch beliebtestes video 53 37 millionen
wer ist das ich habe da ein gebiet das
knappe sache ich habe 50 auch eine
kinderkarte
aufrufe gibt es das video nochmal 40 89
millionen 3,68
wenn das du ich habe 35 9 zu sehen ist
die karte ist natürlich das ziel jetzt
bin ich sage ich muss nochmal derselben
kategorie bleiben auch rufe auch billig
ist das video 29,18 ansprechbarer wagen
oder so ok ich kriege sie hatte das war
locker sieht aus wie 40 jähriger bodykit
erhält ok ihr müsst selber abgeben ich
hab den pokal der kategorie bestes video
474 39 millionen sie kam es macht denen
beschissene ich habe hier sind wir jetzt
gut 21 aka botox kaka auch für circa
möglich
ist echt alles nicht so krass ok
wirklichen dem kanal statt vierter mai
2011 social media sophie und leeren
maschine einkassiert mit dem homepage an
der stelle lehne ich mich mal gar nicht
so weit aus dem fenster und gehe auf
abonnenten 4,55 millionen stück
juli in bern hat mir hier die lobbys und
gewinnt zeit geschenk danke ich glaube
bei der karte nicht so sicher ist dann
ja schon lange dabei kanalstadt abend 28
april 2011 fahrrad statt 210 habe ich
das schon gemacht
kyu alter abgegeben anzahl videos 19.200
ja ja das ist nicht dein ernst wäre dies
mit junge sie haben das play deutlich
abgeben kommt aber jetzt glaube ich
gerade bei dir kommt hat das gesamte us-
566 millionen 2,51 milliarden der ball
ja ich bin mir eigentlich sicher bei der
karte aber ich gehe mal auf anzahl
videos 2177 nissan zwei videos 4031
kanalstadt am 14 oktober 2007 r2 karte
platz gab auch rufe auch beliebtestes
video 33 6 millionen kindern die letzte
karte praktiziert abgezogen denn erst
jetzt
ich weiß nicht wenn ich das jetzt
richtig sagen geworden ich sage
abonnenten 3,21 millionen ja max
geschlagen
das dem heutigen video leute sagt petra
bock gemacht vor dir die leute kommt
jetzt zu einer neuen folge von was das
geht da habe ich zusammen mit dem brot
takers eine richtig geile fussball
challenge gemacht mit den jungs können
[Musik]